[Music]
hello everyone welcome to another TIFF
2019 interview this is for the upcoming
movie Harriet I am so excited to talk to
the team behind the movie about this one
so many places that I want to start but
Cynthia I have to go to you first so
obviously playing Harriet Tubman is an
immense challenge but if you had to
isolate one very specific thing about
the role that was the most intimidating
thing to you what would it be I think I
can I can isolate to a moment and that
was when I had to climb up the side of a
little clip was it cliff it's climbing
up the side of a cliff that was
intimidating because it was really me
doing it so yeah that was intimidating
is I think the physical aspect of of her
I'm trying to make sure that even
through all of that physical activity
that she still remained feminine you
know that she still had femininity about
her because it's not that it was all
second nature to her even though it was
within her that there's still like the
work behind it you have to work to get
to that yeah that's like one of the
beautiful things about the movie a woman
being strong and leading in charge and
finding herself and helping others
through that process I definitely think
you achieved that thank you so I know
you were attached to this project for
many years and we were talking about bad
times with my favorite movies of last
year you've had a lot happen since you
were first attached to this and I
imagine that might kind of rock the boat
a little maybe something came up that
made you think oh no maybe I can't do
Harriet so were there ever any of those
periods and what made you stick with
this project um I don't I think in my
mind I was always going to be doing this
I don't think I was certain that the one
thing that he just happened was this so
I had to make sure that things would
move around it there were things that
might impinge on it but I was like we
have to make it work figure it out and
we'll get to it you know because I knew
that this was a specifically special
project that I wanted to be a part of
yeah definitely is and Casey I'm curious
you've worked with Cynthia I think
you're working with Octavia Spencer
right I can just go down the list a
wonderful leading ladies that you have
worked with so do you notice a shared
trait among all the greats just being
great yeah yeah greatness
that I noticed and I feel incredibly
lucky like on a talent I do to have
worked with the people I've worked with
but working with Cynthia is such a it
was a really transformative experience
for me because we were bringing somebody
so important to me to life and just to
watch her emerge through Cynthia you
know it was such a gift it was a really
deep I don't know it's one of those
experiences that you have and you think
is everything is it ever gonna be this
good again you know what I mean is it
ever gonna be this important is it ever
gonna be this meaningful is that ever
gonna am I ever gonna feel this close to
somebody who lived because I really I
felt very close to Harriet you know it
was a very pure experience for me
that's so beautiful and Leslie you've
had experience playing historical
characters before first what is what are
the pillars of Williams tell that you
needed to bring to screen the best
possible way what were the ones that you
were most nervous about getting on point
well whenever you're not the you know
number one of the Call Sheet you you
know really you're trying to arrive on
the set and like you know sort of drop
into the culture of what's been created
before you got there you know I mean I I
wasn't there for the first couple weeks
and so by the time you get there there's
already a rhythm and there's something
happening and so you're getting there
and you're trying to like just be super
sensitive and and and and you know
assimilate into that culture as quickly
as possible so you don't rock the boat
unless you're intended to rock the boat
which in a way which is a little bit
which is a little bit of what yeah which
is a little bit of what William you know
what they did for each other with what
William did for Harriet and what Harriet
did for Williams that they did they they
they came from very very different
perspectives you know it ends at the
ends of the spectrum you know kind of
trying to achieve the same thing but
from very different as its spectrum so
yeah like yeah we hope that some of that
that alchemy like that's where their
sparks came from on screen we hope do
you
any advice for anybody out there who
might jump into a role like this where
they're playing such a key historical
figure given your experience oh yeah I
mean you know you just you do the
research and then you try to find the
little pathways in yourself those little
pathways to empathy those little
pathways to like where are we the same
what do i what do what what are the
things that I understand about this
person right away and then also you know
that curiosity of you know that's an
interesting decision that he made or she
made I wonder why they did that or how
you get there but I think you first
start with I first start with all the
ways that we're like here all the things
that I understand right away I want to
go back to something you said before
about being a member of the ensemble and
stepping in and not not rocking the boat
and forgive me that this question is
convoluted we're still working on it but
I love this idea of being a lead in a
nun Samba land I know that the the
director is at the helm but you and the
title role what does that mean to you as
far as being a leader in the ensemble
how do you kind of set that tone
appropriately for everybody it means a
lot I take I take very seriously I do
believe that if you're if you're in the
number one position that your job is not
just to play the lead role your job is
to facilitate everyone else on the set
trying to make sure that everyone else
is comfortable lead by example so you
know making sure that I'm prepared
making sure that I'm ready to work
making sure that I'm watching out for
everyone else making sure that I can be
a voice for those who maybe are too
afraid to ask for something or too
afraid to speak about something that's
that's where I see myself
you know me my mood can change the mood
completely so my responsibility is also
to be aware of that you know when when
you're on set she does it better than
almost anyone I've ever seen she's
extraordinary at it yeah it's a big job
yeah that's one of my favorite answers
Casey one specific thing in the story I
really wanted to ask you about
developing is representing Harry it's
narcolepsy that was just one of the
things that really struck me one because
I wasn't super familiar with that but
also that's where your style
a director really shines through so can
you tell me about the process of
developing that and putting it in the
story well it's interesting because as I
did I did seven months of pure research
on here and very quickly you realize
that this is this is this is a huge part
of her story and so um in in looking at
the script and thinking about the script
I thought this is how we're gonna meet
her you know she's and she's unconscious
in a field you know and um and that's
that's the beginning that's our
introduction to her character and it's
um it's a huge part of of her life and
that she accomplished this as a woman in
this period a petite woman an uneducated
woman of the former enslaved person with
narcolepsy really you know with
epileptic seizures she managed to not
only escape but then go back how do you
have the fortitude and the courage to to
go back for other people win at any time
out of your control you might have a
seizure I know this is there's probably
no easy answer to this but it just
astounds me that we've never had a movie
about her before so why do you think
that is I don't know and you know maybe
maybe the world is waiting for the right
time for it to happen and though we wish
it could happen earlier maybe now it is
the right time for it for it to happen
maybe now people are ready to see her
you know she's been waiting and she's
waited long enough yeah absolutely right
I love hearing about happy magic on set
something that comes out of a scene that
you might not have expected whether it's
because I don't know like a production
issue happened or anything for that man
to take this one okay this one this one
you've got someone with you yeah what by
thinking about same one and you take it
okay so well you've seen the movie but
there's a certain point where Harriet
crosses the border into freedom and this
was obviously a very huge moment for me
and I planned it out as the director
does and you know you've scouted
location and you say this is where she's
going to do it um but when we came to
work that day it was pouring rain really
really really pouring rain
and it rained pretty steadily all day
long and and it was getting late and we
had to the airport change there was a
lot going on that day and the mood got
very very pessimistic and to the point
where it's like you're not gonna get the
scene and I'm like what we have to get
the scene it's our it's our last day
here all these production things that
come up and and I'm like no we're gonna
go up to the top of that hill and we're
gonna get the scene and so I called
makeup artists in the hair dressing like
you could get to see mover through
please just got to do this and and um
when you're directing you know things
that some people know but you know it's
hard to communicate the urgency of you
know I need I need it it's daylight you
know it's light that we're talking about
it we might not get anyway so we march
through the mud to the top of this hill
and the sky is black and everybody's
looking at me like are you crazy like
what how is this gonna work and I'm
looking at this little line of blue you
know at the horizon and like just gets
in the air and we start building the
crane and the second the crane was built
Cynthia arrived and this is your gift
it's just being in the moment yeah you
know being able to be available in the
moment and just to be harried in that
moment can I tell you I'm with the skies
parted I mean it's amazing it was
madness the most magical sunset you
could possibly imagine
double rainbows behind us as it
everybody crazy like the sky was like
this ridiculous blue and with like
streaks of red and orange the Sun was
huge and glaring and then there was
there is a double rainbow just behind us
unbelievably it works in freedom and we
look right up to Ruth is most incredible
ridiculous everybody applauded and
pranky and all of a sudden I was like
Harry it was there yeah we felt it all
the time we felt like Harry it was there
yeah you know Harry was gonna make sure
that I walk into that
Oh unique you really been having even
watching this you've been waiting for
this second yeah that's one of my
favorite that was the first time in the
film where it's like you know material
welling up but that was the first time
where I'm like oh oh that's all over now
and I sat in a puddle that real we kept
saying no one is going no one's going to
believe that this isn't CGI'd no one's
gonna believe that this is but that is
real that's how it that's what it what
you saw is what we saw that's what
clouds yeah and that's what matters
before I have to wrap up with you guys I
want to play a Collider game with you
and at this festival we are doing
Collider most memorable so I've got a
list of I think six or seven topics and
I want you to tell me the first thing
that comes to your mind so first off
most memorable film premiere whether
it's one for one of your movies or one
you attended
I'm gonna say bad times in theory oh
good choice each by you right here I've
been to like two or three I don't know I
don't know to Harriet this is one most
memorable meal okay
so Christmas time my mom makes the most
amazing like salmon and I don't eat fish
but when she cooks it I will she made
the most brilliant meal and she it was
the first probably the first time I
managed to get back to London for
Christmas this is like last year and she
made like a whole Christmas dinner and
brought it to the hotel that we're
staying and we've managed to like get
the the private room to have my system
myself my other half we will have
breakfast my best friend was there and
like it was amazing she made the most
amazing that was a good meal yeah for me
it's Lisbon Portugal I was 17 and I had
paia for the first time and and I
thought it was the food of the gods I
was like this is the most amazing thing
I've ever eaten in my life that's kind
of divine you know I might have another
one for you it's a beaut take it okay
Paris I think it was 2011 I want to say
I took myself to Paris by myself I was
there for a week I found a little
restaurant I was on my own and I sat
outside and there's a park opposite mean
I'm watching hot and I ordered like and
I don't really drink very much but I was
in Paris I was like I'm gonna have a
small glass of desert wine and I had
like when I was eating me like a meal of
duck confit and it was amazing and I
spent like two hours just sitting
watching people go by like something out
of a freaking movie is amazing
it was awesome you got anything I have
to go still either that or if you could
only eat one food for the rest of your
life motive a yeah
mine would be can i it's is it can I
have a certain meal yeah Emile
Thanksgiving
Thanksgiving that every day for the rest
of my life I want the turkey
I want the mac and cheese I want the
stuffing want the cranberry sauce I want
the mashed potatoes the yams
what is this is a big one now what is
the most memorable scene you've ever
shot if not the one you guys just mainly
about that's pretty okay so one of my
favorites is at well too so one of my
favorites is when John and I filmed that
it's like a breakup basically it's when
she realizes that he's with another
woman and I just remember it being
heartbreaking but but it felt so good
and cathartic to do so I that was an
amazing idea that was AK Momo and with
this one here is when it's the first
time she is asked what name she wants to
go by and she that's when she chooses
Harriet Tubman I just remember thinking
what a moment to be able to like speak
her name that way like give her the
agency to link say it out and out again
yeah same one it's Harriet's like I mean
that was one of the most incredible
things that's ever happened in my life
it is true it was magic it was you felt
the crack even the crankiest most
cynical crew person who's like that was
Harry I mean yeah well burst into tears
but yeah it was amazing it was amazing I
see the thank you Faison say it again I
said I see the thing he faced on again
we ended up with Thanksgiving dinner
last time so it worked good I have a
two-year-old so I'm tired all the time
so like my brain doesn't work as fast
but I just didn't I did the Sopranos
movie it's called Newark no you know
another great ensemble and it was
probably you know one of those ensemble
scenes from that you know we did this
one scene where like kind of all the
guys were together and you know
Alessandro's they're you know ray
Liotta's there and you know Billy
Magnussen you know we're and and kind of
everybody had a little thing to do so
you know it was like it was like you
know just passing the ball like that
between like 11 12 p.m. when it's right
it's just yeah that was pretty member
I'm gonna end on one more big one for
you guys most memorable fear overcome
most memorable fear overcome walking
into waters in the middle of the night
not being in really to see the bottom of
it like just like alright yeah that was
a little bit of a fear yeah doing a
movie on Harriet Tubman yeah take a left
again I am like I just I've been talking
about this we were just talking about
earlier about this I was telling Casey I
feel like her you know she must have
felt you know really being at the helm
of this big creative thing I just
finished my first original album you
know of music and that was super scary
you know and I start I started telling
people I was gonna do it before I'd
written one song the next house is gonna
be all originals so yeah just like
finding my voice in that way guys so
much this was such a pleasure again a
huge congratulations on this movie I
hope you have a wonderful time thank you
thank you so much everybody out there
thank you so much for watching this
interview before we say goodbye we have
to give a big thank you to our sponsors
its Nordstrom Canada thank you so much
for making these interviews happen do
not leave this video without liking and
sharing it and tune back in soon for
more tip interviewing